tiffany on a un petit contre-plongée
dans ton décolleté c'est très joli à
l'image salue aujourd'hui je suis où je
suis au parc de belleville vous
commencez à avoir l'habitude c'est là
c'est la foi c'est la quatrième et je
vais passer de l'autre côté de la caméra
parce qu'avant qui parle
envie d'essayer quelque chose tous
ensemble j'ai avec moi un jeu de cartes
un tout petit peu particulier avant de
vous faire voir ce qu'à l'intérieur il
faut que je prépare une prédiction des
cette prédiction
je vais la faire devant les internautes
veulent à faire devant vous écris ici
comme ça dans la vidéo on verra ce que
j'écris à l'avant ce jeu la vache
geoffrey je te confie la prédiction si
tu peux la mettre dans ta petite
pochette s'il te plait merci tu es
magnifique est formidable je vais car
c'est un jeu de cartes particulier parce
que ce sont des cartes truquées des red
bull marca je jouis alors il rit parce
que oui forcément en voie de marquage
sont marqués mais mélanger quand même
elles sont marquées de 1 à
on n'a pas révisé
nous protestions s'agit de west ya pas
les deux jokers jeu c'est forcément quel
numéro est écrit derrière quelqu'un je
les connais par coeur exactement c'est
ce qu'on appelle un chapelet je me suis
entraîné à les retenir presse que vous
êtes réceptif on a fait peut-être ce
petit fadiga mais non moi mec regarde
mon bien jamais tu m'a foutu un sacré
talent tu vas noté des choses au fur et
à mesure si je te dis par exemple de
noter deux carreaux tu mets 2 avec un
cadre de travail
donc tu écris 4 avec un thé et jeff tu
vas devoir retrouver le numéro qui est
caché derrière le cadre de trèfle mais
je vais t'aider à faire ça je vais
t'aider quand même imaginer une grande
horloge d une horloge qui fait tic-tac
tic-tac tic-tac tic-tac eyal aiguille
qu'il bouge et elle bouge de plus en
plus vite de plus en plus et de plus en
plus vite elle va s'arrêter sur une aire
plein maintenant sur quelle race est
arrêté 15h ou 16h apparemment il veut
pas changer donc 15 heures je vais te
donner la carte ou ya marqué le numéro
ne regardez pas pour qu'il y ait du
suspense je les tue la garde d'un témoin
sans la retourner
super formidable donc je peux noter
valet de carreau et et en face du
du cadre de trêve qui marque 15 les
carreaux ses portes ou à julie le valet
de carreau le valet de carreau je n'ai
pas choisi par hasard je les prix parce
que il est à l'opposé en fait du
potentiel cadre de trêve c'est à dire
c'est un nombre relativement gros
d'après toi julie qu'elle quel numéro et
marquer derrière le valet de carreau 46
pourquoi 46 ça des sorties comme ça tu
peux changer s'il te plaît non non non
non non non non à 46,46 pareil décide
pas regarder ce qui est en dessous si
jamais vous voyez pour garder du
suspense 46 allez ici mais comme jeff
formidable et alors pour terminer je
vais te demander à toi petit fanny
quelque chose d'assez compliqué sur
toutes les cartes
je te demande et d'en choisir wind
n'importe laquelle écoute moi tu peux
prendre n'importe quelle carte tu peux
même prendre la dame de coeur si tu veux
mais tout le monde prend la dame de
coeur mais tu peux le prendre quand même
après avoir si il ya les as tu vas
spontanément tu vois là tu vas dire une
carte n'importe quelle carte par contre
tu tu prends le temps de le faire pour
que ce soit un vrai choix
ça peut être un choix classique comme un
choix atypique c'est toi que ça regarde
prend pas le cadre de très cool d'être
carreaux potentiellement on a peut-être
bon donc choisi n'importe quelle carte
le roi de pique
pourquoi l'aurait depuis voulu faire
compliqué atypiques ou parce que bien
mélanger d'imposer à oui c'est vrai ça
ce serait une influence alors si je
voulais le roi de pique
mais peut-être que tu voudrais le trois
piques et que tu as mal prononcé depuis
crois qu'ils croient qu'ils croient
qu'ils croient tic
il est juste là ok tu le prends tu le
fais ce que tu veux pour le monde
ok on va faire un pas capital hâtif de
ce qui s'est passé au tout départ j'ai
demandé à mon pote jeff
imaginez pour le cadre de trèfle
d'imaginer pour le cadre de trêve quel
nom il y avait derrière tu m'as dit 15
est ce que tu peux retourner ton 15 et
nous faire voir c'est bon vu ta tête oui
derrière le cadre de très longues à 15
regarder un petit peu son visage agacé
la julie vaccaro 12h46 hat est devenu
vraiment spontanément veux tu retournes
est de 46 à carreaux et que 46 et tu
m'as dit une carte au hasard celle que
tu voulais toi tu m'as dit le roi de
pique le roi de pique que je t'ai mis
dans la manière tant le roi de pique on
a le 30
le 30 derrière le roi de pique c'est
bien le 30 exactement la carte que je
voulais c'est celle que je voulais moi
parce que comme on est ami il faut me
croire sur parole mais non moi je veux
plus te voir le petit bout de papier
bien joué et jeff depuis le départ il ya
un bout de papier cachée jusqu'ici juste
ici à une petite prédiction jamais fait
au départ pour jeff mais surtout pour
tiffany vous fait voir ce qui est de
marquer dans le papier depuis le départ
abrupt qui se déchirent dans le papier
il y avait simplement marquer 30
mais eux ils savaient puisque je l'avais
écrit avant vous ils sont tous
influençable et j'espère bien
évidemment avec autorité knotty la
dernière fois qu'on s'est vus merci
beaucoup les amis j'espère que ça vous a
plu vous a fait marrer de voir que vous
étiez potentiellement manipulable si
cette vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez
mettre un petit pouce en l'air n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner à la chaîne vous
pouvez aussi lâché un petit commentaire
on peut parler de ce qui vient ce passé
ça fera plaisir et rendez vous demain à
17 heures pour le prochain mentale blog
ciao